comedian Andy Richter's a bonafide
outdoorsman and a real man's man nobody
else is sitting on that couch that's
right
Andy's not one of these guys who worries
about how much SPF is on his face unless
his family has a history of skin cancer
I don't know do we know that do we know
if we should probably find that out
today on how to be a man Andy Richter
shows us how to fish Andy pulled up
looking like a 1960s movie star and an
earthquake of a man probably where they
got the name Richter scale mmm nice
writing there was Richter's infamous
handshake test yeah put her there
how you doing I'm doing real good how
you doing Andy I've been good I knew
this morning when I woke up everywhere I
was gonna be it was exactly where I was
supposed to be gonna say that again I'm
not going to though now you don't have
to him you play your cards right I might
let you in on a little man secret it
just sounds kind of where's I'm man
secretive you got gel in your hair
what is it that you like about fishing
it's probably just the basic man versus
beast dynamic you know just me and this
pole fighting that creature I mean did
that fish ever work to bring home a
paycheck that fish ever go through the
process of getting a kid and doing
Episcopal School no [ __ ] you fish
because this is a simulation there's no
this is my pool as you know we couldn't
get the permit for the lake but there's
no fish in here I just want you to know
that now it's very important to find the
balance point of your rod because you
need to know where that point is or else
you're gonna be fighting that ride all
day long what's funny no I'm sorry it's
balance your rod like you know like pick
your you know your your penis
Oh cuz Robbie it's like another word for
penis so Andy I got it I gotta ask you
what's the secret what's the Nancy oh
that when you're hanging out with your
buddies with your fellow men it's
awesome to like think up names for them
that aren't their names like they like
it since you're Jason you would be like
j-dog I I know I know what nicknames are
Andy in part The Sharper got me oh I
miss my dog I miss Diane the the dog's
name was was Diane yeah
he's named after who Diane Sawyer I mean
what other news woman would you name a
dog after you couldn't wander you
wouldn't call it dog Barbra I could call
the dog Sawyer and I wouldn't in cool
Sawyer Diane Diane the dogs dead right
no the dog is delicate
turns out Andy was a giant [ __ ] which
was disappointing on some level but made
me feel better as a person we'll see you
next time on how to be a man for more
awesome videos that teach you how to be
a man subscribe to our YouTube channel
and follow us on Twitter